hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
all right and hey [__] your week how's
your day going
huh did you wake up this morning have a
conference call and get kicked right you
[__] red nuts
like I did
oh There's No Business Like Show
Business Like no business I know
take that idea and go [__] yourself
ah
whatever it's just it's just it's a
theme it's I've always had to do it I
always get to go [__] yourself and then
I take the go [__] yourself I put it on
my back and then I walk it up the hill
myself and then you get up there and
everybody's like you know I knew that go
[__] yourself was gonna [__] miss
that and the other and you got to sit
there going oh yeah I know you did you
were in my corner
ah anyway
though who gives a [__] I had a great
[__] week
um
uh
I went to uh
I flew my helicopter and there was a
couple of airports that I was telling
you like I gotta I got a solo into these
things
and uh I gotta get the monkey off my
back here what the [__] is this all
right so
of course the time I have free time I go
over there
it's windy as [__] right windy as [__]
if you fly
you know a light
helicopter like I do so it was like 30
knots out
um
and I was just like I don't give a [__]
I have a fully articulated main rotor if
if is any sort of problem I can always
just set it down I can slow down I can
just turn around and go back to the
airport who gives a [__] right
visibilities you know
would have 10 statute miles who gives a
[__] so of course the second I get up
there
visibility goes down
and uh you know it's bumpy or whatever
and I was just like yeah but it's fine
you know I can see this far I can see
over there there's an airport right
there I I I'm all right
all right this isn't insane and I
couldn't figure it out it was like windy
and the visibility sucked because
usually if it's windy the visibility is
clear
because it's blowing all the all the
all the [__] out of there right
when there's no wind you have poor
visibility so that that's that's one of
the funny things about Aviation if you
want a nice smooth ride you know your
visibility is going to suck if you want
to like go up there and it the whole
world looks looks like a [__]
um
what do you call it one of those little
little postcard
you know like that [__] three days
out of the Year where you can see the
downtown LA buildings and behind it you
see a snow-capped mountain right
those days are the days you want to go
fly but it's bumpy as [__] so I was
flying
and I flew over to the five and I went
took it south
and uh I wanted to I was trying to go to
this airport called Corona which is a
uncontrolled airport meaning there's no
Tower you just talk to the traffic in
the pattern
if nobody talks to you because you're
trying to figure out which you know
which way the wind's blowing traffic
advisory whatever
of course nobody's in the pattern or
whatever
um oh but the first thing is I had to
fly by Fullerton
airport and what's funny is Fullerton I
swear to God I don't think I've ever
gotten on the
on the radio with them and they either
didn't yell at me or they were in the
process of yelling at somebody else
foreign
Fullerton is like your dad in the 70s
you know he's never happy so
I uh
I get on with them I'm on the 605 and
the five and there's this big like radio
tower thing there that's kind of hard to
see but you know I've looked at my map I
see you know
how high it is and I see my minimum safe
altitude so even if I don't see it I'm
gonna be over it by like you know 500
feet or whatever
so I'm waiting to make my radio call
because there's a bunch of people in the
pattern talking
and the tower says to somebody all right
you know
what did he say he said you're number
three after that Bonanza or whatever and
the guy goes confirmed he goes we have
that traffic in sight right
the [__] guy in the tower goes
basically yells at him saying you're
looking at the wrong plane
all right that's he was looking at the
first plane he thought it was plain
number two so he was getting in line to
[__] land and there would be another
plane right on his [__] ass right
so the guy yells at him
and he goes that's the wrong plane you
should never make your turn until you
confirm
uh blah blah blah blah goes that's a
cardinal error
[Laughter]
pilot tried to defend himself I think
that that's when the guy came back and
and said there was a car I mean the
[__] visibility was horrible right so
you know Tower is right whatever so then
I'm getting on it's just like yeah
you I just want to transition
so
they told me it was cool
keep it at 1600 or above and I was like
fine and um
I ended up getting you know I was
waiting for them and then when you go
along the 91 when you when you
transition past Fullerton Airport when
you go along the 91 you almost have to
be like right over the highway
um
because there's that permanent temporary
TFR over Disneyland and it almost it
just touches the highway at this one
point so I got past that and then
Fullerton goes you know resume on
navigation and if whatever
I could fly whatever altitude I wanted
to and then I got the frequency change
and then I was out of the airspace so I
was like all right fine so now I'm going
over to Corona
visibility is getting worse a little bit
but I just keep looking around and I see
all these Pockets where it's not too bad
where I would be fine
I said well I can go I can fly over
there I could set it down here or
whatever right so
I'm going to Corona and then all of a
sudden it just gets really bumpy and I'm
really getting like tossed around and
[__] but I was just like all right I was
just looking at the hills I was flying
through created like a Venturi so the
air was really flowing through there I
was like I just need to be a little
higher a little lower or whatever I
don't know what and just slow down
I got through that I go over to Corona I
get on the phone on the phone I get on
the radio
nobody's talking but I with my avionics
I can see which way the wind's going
so I just joined the downwind I land I
do it everything's fine
and now I'm gonna fly up to Ontario this
isn't boring you guys but this was like
a big deal for me I go up to Ontario and
I'm thinking I'm either going to be in
Chino or Riverside's airspace or
possibly both so I'm following the
highway up there the 15 and lo and
behold if you just follow the 15 you're
not neither Airport's airspace which was
great because it gave me plenty of time
to listen to the Adis which is the
information the current information of
Ontario now Ontario
is like
you know Jet Blue
you know American uh Southwest like real
[__] [__]
and then I'm coming over there my little
[__] egg beater so
I listened to the 80s I get the
information and I'm like okay here we go
and it ended up being like and by owner
also when I flew up north it got really
clear it was just sorted down along like
the water and stuff and there was like a
storm coming in
um
and it wasn't as bumpy but then also up
near the the San Gabriel mountains that
the visibility up there was really poor
like I couldn't even see the [__]
Mountains from where I was
so uh
I built this up for years I would just
never go over there I would I would land
it bracket because it was a little you
know Delta
airport and it's just like pretty much
just
you know weekend warrior jerk offs like
me Landing there right this is like a
big deal and essentially without getting
into the aviation conversation all I
just said to them was like hey is it
okay if I do a low approach and straight
out departure and they were like yeah
fine and then I said okay and then I did
it
foreign
why did I make such a big [__] deal
about that it gave me a lot of
confidence but of course as I'm coming
in
I hear him talking to this southwest
um flight and uh they're saying that you
know they want to take out first so they
go confirm that you have that traffic in
sight and you know the visibility was
bad so I'm sitting there going I think
that's it right and uh
I was like you know you know looking for
traffic whatever but I knew the guy was
on the [__] ground so it wasn't like
a problem and then I I get you know just
needed to fly for another like 15
seconds so I could totally confirm that
you know that is the airplane right so
um
I see it and they go okay after it takes
off you know just caution wake
turbulence blah blah blah
and uh
I just set it down on the numbers
is what I did because I just figured
like all right because I always get
nervous about that weight charging with
[__] I know like when I'm landing
behind a big plane like that all you do
is you just you just see where they land
on the runway and you just land beyond
that and you'll be fine and this thing
was like taken off so I was just like
all right I'll land is far to this side
as a Runway I will touch down
Because by the time I was even coming in
the [__] guide already taken off and
was gone I probably could have landed
anywhere and I would have been fine but
it was already like a windy day so
long story short I uh I was able to uh
do that and then I flew back
to
um
where I keep my helicopter
and uh I felt like a million bucks for
like two days and it was funny I'm
coming home when I was
I was telling the lovely knee about it
and she's just going uh-huh
uh-huh oh all right I'm like no this is
like a big deal I mean I was like
Landing right after us you know
Southwest Jet took off she's like yeah
okay
[Laughter]
could give a [__] hey guys I I'm gonna
uh
hey guys did I just say that like we're
all at us I'm gonna come with the
slumber party
energy
um you know my kids got a [__] thing
on on the uh on the uh what do you call
it the uh shelf here
it's of like the solar system
and I saw this thing the other day on
Instagram or YouTube or one of those
dumbass places that I [__] hang out
on the internet
they will it said what people think this
solar system looks like what it actually
looks like
and it's like first of all I resent the
fact that you're [__] thinking that
you know what I think the solar system
looks like I have no [__] idea what
the solar system looks like all right
but I did think that the sun was just
sort of sitting there and everything was
going around it and this thing had it
looking like the sun was just hurling
through space
you know go in a good
you know like when someone's driving too
fast in a parking lot
and you got your kid and you do that hat
that you do that Dad thing like
it's always some young kid with some
stupid ass [__] hat on her whatever
the [__] it is they're doing
you know or one of these cologne guys
you know this is this I don't know what
it is about my neighborhood but there's
just a lot of guys with beards and
colognes
acting like that is just completely
acceptable uh it's very like
1983. you know it isn't the the 60s long
hair it isn't the 70s let it be sort of
[__] Frank poncharello haircut it's
that [__] uh
the in between there
that and the before the flat top came
back in the 80s
um anyway I had no [__] idea that
that the sun is moving
I mean why wouldn't it be it's [__]
in space right it's only gets Tethered
to anything
I just I just don't [__] understand
how the F how did somebody figure out
that it was moving
is it I mean that's what I it was funny
is the [__] there was no explanation
on the video it was just a video it was
like and it just said what people think
the solar system looks like what it
really looks like and there was just no
explanation was like all right
well it wasn't moving in the first one
the sun wasn't and then the second one
the sun was moving so I don't know
here's a question for you I think this
is an easy easy one would you rather
float off into space
like George Clooney
oh would you like rather die alone in
the ocean no sharks you're not going to
get eaten by a shark you're just going
to be [__]
floating out there you fell off some uh
Circus Circus [__] Cruise or some
[__] you know or your spouse just took
out a life insurance policy on you
um
I remember seeing that some guy did that
to his wife on his [__] honeymoon I
mean Jesus Christ can we get some
[__] information out there on how to
break up with somebody
or that guy who [__] you know
took his wife's regulator off while they
were scuba diving
and drowned her
I mean I can be honest with you like
my wife can be annoying
[Laughter]
but what the [__]
if I got to be honest with you uh if
you're listening to this podcast and
you're thinking about killing
the person that you're with male or
female just get out of the relationship
even if getting out of it means you're
not going to get the life insurance who
gives a [__]
you're not getting it anyway you're
gonna get caught and you're gonna go to
jail I cannot [__] believe
the amount of people out there
who don't commit crime
and then the first crime that they're
going to try to get away with is they
try to murder somebody
the one that everybody's going to give a
[__] about oh
you're going to jail
you're going to [__] jail
um
that is really I would I will tell you
though like the amount of people out
there
that are capable of that at least that's
how that show makes you feel whatever it
is First 48 the guy with the [__]
horse head that that guy with the white
hair
I mean he he literally he looks like a
retired vampire he's the only way to
describe the guy
um
like he he's a [__] ghost
and he has a TV gig and I forget what
his name is but anyway the uh
the amount of [__] people
that are like you know upstanding
citizens in their community and then you
know he or she always took the kids to
softball and you know it was a
fun-loving person
and they you know that's
I don't know I don't know if there's
psychos or they just don't have anybody
to talk to and then they just get that
idea in their head
and you can't [__]
you got to have somebody you can
literally talk to about that right
I don't know
I'll tell you what's a [__] up thing
is when you're married
and you go out and you get life
insurance
you know like you know do the right
thing make sure your kids and your wife
and everybody's gonna be all right and
it's just like okay so not only did I
get life insurance I also just gave my
wife motive
[Laughter]
like I am now
um like worth something
dare I say worth more dead than alive
that's the thing
well you know when they go to get life
insurance you can't give them so much
money
that you make yourself obsolete
I don't want to blame the victim here
all right but when you don't have two
nickels to rub together don't go out and
get a million dollars of Life Insurance
I mean if you do I would I highly
recommend you start cooking your own
[__] meals
all right
um
because that seems
to be the biggest
reoccurring thing like the biggest
motive
that I find when I watch those things
because my wife watches the uh she
watches the murder shows
um
we had like the best day we just had
like a day we just hung out the whole
afternoon it was the [__] best
um
I can't remember what the hell we
laughed about we went out
she of course went to some stores looked
at some [__]
I got my beard shaped up at the
barbershop
um
how was I talking to her about
that made her laugh so hard oh I told
her about this time when I was younger
how I'd hooked up with this chick and
she was like a gymnast and now her whole
body felt like a knee
and she goes oh yeah she goes I remember
you telling me that I said yeah like oh
it was like spooning with an ironing
board and I don't even know why it just
struck her
is funny just that image of it
and uh
she just started [__] she was laughing
so hard it like made me laugh and it
just sort of set the tone for the day
and we just had like a [__] great day
and um
I don't know and then like we go home
right
and then
the kids come back from school and all
of that stuff so then we're in the
bubble
and then we get them all down you know
for the night
it's funny my trying to put my son to
bed now he has every
delaying tactic
you know I'll be like changing his
diaper and goes poopy potty poopy potty
I go oh yeah you're gonna go poopy in
the potty he's like yeah
and then I set him on the Block he's
just sitting there not doing anything
maybe he goes like number one that's it
then I I go to brush his teeth and I
finally got that down I only put a
little bit of toothpaste on because he's
not gonna brush him he's just going to
eat the toothpaste and then
I I put a little more toothpaste on and
I try to brush his teeth but he pretty
much eats just eats the toothpaste but
there's not toothpaste on there so I
brush his teeth then I read him I swear
to God like seven books
then I put him in bed and then he has to
kiss everybody good night and then
as I I go to leave he goes he'll be like
dada dada I tired
I tired I go yeah I know you're tired so
go to bed he goes
my nose nose hurt nose hurt I'm like all
right go over kiss his nose
itchy itchy he's like just doing all of
this [__] and I'm like
try not to laugh and it's just like all
right buddy let's just
let's just go to bed and then finally
when he gets I don't know what it is he
just has that
he sort of exhausts
his final appeal
all right
and then he realizes that he's not gonna
get
he's going to get convicted he just has
to go to bed he just goes like all right
he like waves like right in my face all
right buddy good night night all right
good night all right good night like on
a loop
and then like the 15th time he says it
uh you know night night I go all right
buddy and he goes okay
he does like this flop and slams himself
down on the bed like he's he's in
wrestling
it's [__] hilarious and then he just
two seconds later he's just out
um
and then last night I was hanging with
my daughter and I was uh
you know there's something really cool
about being an old dad is you know that
that you know that they're up on all the
new [__]
right so what you want to do is you just
show them the old [__]
right all of this old stuff that none of
their friends are going to see so last
night we were watching The Pink Panther
um and now she like loves the song She
Thinks She you know I gotta watch in
Bugs Bunny
um The Pink Panther
you know I got my little uh
little radio speaker and um
my son's listening to like [__] from the
1950s and then he also like loves the
soundtrack to cars so he listens to like
all the new stuff like my wife plays all
the uh all the Contemporary [__] so I'm
like the I'm not even like a classic
hits I'm like I'm like classic hits
meets like oldies
like um
my son is like a beast on drums already
like he's [__] killing it he wants to
play every day he's like Dad boom boom
bap I'm like all right buddy let's get
out there and uh
he just keeps playing and playing and
playing and I finally just go all right
we gotta go inside for dinner and then
he like cries
because he wants to keep playing and I'm
just like oh my God this is the [__]
greatest thing ever
um so of course I'm playing I'm like you
know
everything from James Gatson to John
Bonham and uh but there's a song by the
uh Jive bombers called Bad Boy
that both him and my daughter love
and uh so whatever so I do all of that
stuff and I just have like a great day
had a great day you know
getting a little better at being a pilot
and stuff and then
we end the night
just watching all these people that get
caught trying to kill their spouse or
they killed their spouse
at the end of the night it just [__]
cracks me up
and I'm always like why do you watch
this [__] this is literally the SNL
sketch and she's just like well you know
I just I just watch it because I want to
like think about what would I do if I
was in that situation
which is the funniest [__] ever to me
I get it I guess I get it I don't know I
don't know but we also watched The Real
Housewives of New Jersey
um
which is just clearly the best one like
the level of skin cancer that's going to
be going on like the guys on that show
like I've never seen a sunburned Italian
before I didn't even think it was
[__] possible these guys like
did they like
Lazy Boy brown brown leather chair Brown
and then their foreheads
are all [__] the guy that is marrying
that one chick who reminds me of the
lizard in that [__] movie uh that
that thing was uh that YouTube video
where the dude was tripping
in the closet and he was talking all
that's I can't find that [__] I gotta
find that video
um
she's marrying this [__] guy I swear
to God it looks like he stuck his head
in a [__] microwave maybe it's it's
the
it's got to be the HD cameras because
there's no way these guys are walking
around like that
um
but I do like it because they're all
like
all like they're younger than me but
they're almost my age
and they're all [__] jacked they all
still work out like I know a couple of
them you know
they got the juice going on
they definitely have a little juice with
their eggs if you know what I mean but
um
I've been trying to get my ass in shape
like I gotta like stop this podcast here
in a second because uh
I don't have any reads this week or
whatever so I'm gonna have to pull up
the podcast a little bit short here
because I haven't eaten breakfast yet
and I gotta go uh
I have to go [__] work out
oh [__] uh aerobic Billy here
um anyway
um
shut this off here sorry now I'm
distracted anyway I had a great [__]
day and a great week
despite you know this [__] business
always kicking me in the balls you know
it's just it is it is what it is I got
off the phone he was like and I just
said you know what I go
every project I've ever worked on this
is how it goes this is how it goes and
then I do this this this and this and
then it gets there and everybody's like
oh you know what that was good and they
let me do it again so who gives a [__]
right I don't have a real job
right I really don't
I don't give a [__] I'm over it look at
me I'm [__] over it
um also by the way you know I didn't
know that I really kind of stumbled onto
some when I when I was talking about as
a guy that I finally realized that
sadness is an emotion I got so many
[__] emails from people
um
from men like talking about like you
know that actually helped me out it's
kind of [__] hilarious
that as men were not allowed to feel all
of those healing feelings you know
crying sadness all of that like the
amount of guys listening to this right
now like Oh shut the [__] up
this [__] you know that's gay right
like you can't
so stupid it's so stupid and I'm
thinking like that's kind of why we die
before they do and you know what's even
funnier is they don't even kind of they
don't want to deal with it
you know what I mean
tell your wife you're sad all she's
gonna do is see if you're sad because of
something that she did
all right and if it's not something that
she did she could give a [__]
it's all hilarious all right that's the
podcast everybody have a great great uh
weekend yeah [__] and I will talk to
you on Monday
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday January 23rd
I'm sorry February 23rd February 23 2000
and uh we'll go with 15. I know what
you're thinking Jesus Bill what happened
to your voice let me what happened to my
voice it's [__] February that's what
happened to my voice okay it's winter
out I was just in Southeast Asia
bleeding and breathing in [__]
pollution and then I was in [__] New
York City you know hanging out with that
animal Paul verzi
yeah Jesus Christ I'm drinking throat
code too I don't know what happened I
was kind of fighting off a cold although
the whole time I was in New York but
there was just so many people that I
wanted to see and all of them uh turned
out to be raging alcoholics so
you know what are you gonna I've
actually been doing really well
like I haven't drank in like a week
oh man well me and this other guy my the
other guy's name will remain nameless
all right because I'm old school
I don't name names
okay I'm not taking notes I'm not going
to write a book someday
some tell all book about every [__] that
I went out and smoked a [__] cigar
with and drank booze with and all the
[__] that they said to me
it's a great thing about alcohol you
can't really remember it anyways
somewhere in my brain there used to be a
tell-all book and it's gone
and I think that's a good thing I think
it strengthens
relationship friendships
when you [__] drink it away anyways I
was staying at a hotel
and uh for whatever reason the bartender
just decided that he had to do something
to take inventory or some [__] so the
bar was open all night
and uh it was hilarious we were we were
staying at the hotel right
and um
I don't I didn't really remember what
happened it was just basically it was
one of those things where the place was
full and then it was half full and then
it was like me and this other comic just
sitting there no it wasn't fuzzy
and it wasn't any of the Rose Bowl
Legends all right it was somebody else
and we were just sitting there
and uh you know
and of course you know the deal once it
gets to around four or five o'clock in
the morning right you get a text from
your lady right then the text becomes a
phone call
and then she comes down there in her
bathrobe with the [__] rolling pin
and drags you up Nia said when she came
downstairs I had a full scotch
not a full Scotch probably a half full
scotch and I it was tilted so far in my
hand it was almost pouring out of the
glass but it wasn't
and um
and the next day I had to get up early
and I had to fly back to finally be back
out you know out here at my house and uh
Jesus Christ
I gotta tell you man
that's the closest I've come to just you
know like when you've drank so much
and someone just goes like hey you want
to get breakfast you just gotta tell
them to stop talking like just please
just don't bring up breakfast
or I'm gonna puke now normally people be
like what the [__] you talking about but
the look on my face and the dead serious
tone she just knew so she was like all
right and I forget what the [__] I had
I don't even remember but I was just
like you know what the old freckles here
oh Billy bread face needs to [__]
shut it down for a while so uh
you know whatever I'm like [__] eight
days into it and I have no desire
to drink again for a while I think I'm
just gonna [__] I think I might have
a couple of Pops towards the end of the
month and then I'm gonna go clean and
[__] uh March gonna go in like a lamb
it out like a lamp going to go a whole
31 days no booze no cigar
right no cigars I'm just going to be me
and my [__] thoughts how long is that
month gonna [__] drag
you know
I gotta finish up some [__] anyways I
might as well do that every once in a
while you got to give you a liver a
[__] break
right wouldn't that work well anyways
I'm recording this Sunday night I
apologize for how late it got up uh last
week I actually recorded it Monday
morning and um I just have really bad
internet where I'm at I don't know why
and uh you know why because it's
technology and nothing works out for me
so what I do now is I just [__]
I'm just going to start recording them
I'm going to upload them to my computer
and then I'm just going to drive to a
local [__] Wi-Fi I'm writing a script
coffee house and I'll just upload them
there so you [__] can stop [__]
bitching about it and everything will be
fine
but I know you guys like to [__] so
it's kind of good when they're up late
you know it'd be even better what if I
did two podcasts a week and both of them
were kind of late then you could [__]
twice
and maybe you could feel twice as good
about your life would you like that
would you like that what would you like
if I did another because I'm thinking
about doing it in fact
you know what
maybe just maybe next week there might
be a big announcement about a possible
second podcast that I'm going to be
doing which would be a culmination of uh
some maybe some classic clips from the
old ones and then me also just going off
on topics that you guys pick
you know rent a rent or something like
that I don't know what the [__] I'm
gonna call it you know what I'm going to
call the podcast
you know
I don't know what the epilogue I have no
idea what the [__] I'm gonna call it but
I'm thinking of doing a random Thursday
every once in a while maybe a couple of
Thursdays who knows maybe slowly I'll
just do this like a full-time [__]
podcast five days a week like a real
radio show I'll quit doing stand up and
I'll just stay in a little tree house
talking to myself five days a [__]
week and you guys can slowly listen to
me slip it uh
now you can listen to me slowly slip
into madness not slowly listen to me
slip into madness
Listen to Me Slowly slip into mag
there's something [__] wrong with my
brain you know the more I do this
podcast the more I understand the grades
I got in high school weren't necessarily
my fault
you know I just think it's the way the
synapses fire so anyways it's it's
[__] 5 42.
5 42 p.m uh I got a big day tomorrow I'm
doing the goddamn Comedy Jam again Josh
Adam Meyers and uh as you guys know I
always go down there and whatever
drummer do a little bit stand up and
then you jam with the band and I always
whatever drummer I'm imitating I always
dress up like them because uh you know I
want to keep it it's got to be a goof if
I'm going to do it you know I couldn't
just sit down Bill Burr behind a [__]
I'd look like a jerk off but if I dress
up like an idiot then he could laugh at
me and then I can play drums and
everybody has a good time and this
there's no tension there
there's nobody sitting in the crowd
going wait a minute does he actually
think that he can also do this as a
profession no I don't I'm just having a
good time so anyways
I'm not going to tell you the drama I'm
dressing up as because that's always
supposed to be a surprise for the people
come to the show so anyways
um
so I'm trying on the costume tonight
right I put the wig on and I got the
[__] sunglasses
the jacket and the t-shirt and all that
[__] right and I come downstairs to show
Nia and as I'm going down there right my
[__] my dog Cleo is in the bedroom
with her and the door is closed and I'm
like
what if my [__] pit bull doesn't
recognize me what's gonna happen right
and I [__] open the door I'm like hey
Nia my dog just goes
[__] launches herself at the [__]
door and I close the door and I'm going
Cleo and I'm not taking off the wig cuz
I'm thinking like she'll smell me right
how does this work I'm actually doing an
experiment behind this brand new door
that I just [__] had put in that cost
me a [__] fortune downstairs right so
I'm going Cleo it's me relax okay relax
and she stops barking then I open it up
again and she just goes flipping the
[__] out
I finally had to take off the wig and
the sunglasses but dude she went to
[__] this mode
and when pitbulls go to [__] this mode
it's too late to take the wig off
so my wife had to totally [__] calm
her down and the dog was just looking at
me like
sideways for like five minutes
almost like don't do that to me you
don't know how close you just came do
you understand that you don't know how
[__] close you came
uh
not [__] not pit bulls I'm not [__]
on pit bulls because uh once you get a
pit bull you actually realize how many
other dogs act exactly like [__] pit
bulls they just don't have the
capability
you know what I mean
it's like if some little torp said I'm
gonna [__] kill you do you just laugh
and keep walking that's like one of
those little Chihuahuas but if a big guy
said I'm gonna [__] kill you you'd be
you'd be afraid you're like you'd call
somebody and be like can you beat that
guy up for me that's what pit bulls are
because there's this little [__] dog
every I [__] hate this dog there's
two dogs when I walk my dog that I
[__] hate
all right
there's this one little [__] dog he
lives
whatever it's allowed to live saying he
lives like he's making payments
this [__] dog lives at this house
with these people that allow him
to live although I don't know that they
[__] like the dog because it's always
outside and they have one of these
driveways that's like a little horseshoe
right so you got you know entrance and
an exit could spin right around
it's probably fat people living there
right fat people can't back up cars
that's why I didn't know if you know
that that's why they have the backup
cameras now
it's because the fatties when they would
turn the neck fat would stop their head
and they could only look so far and I
was causing a lot of problems
so uh that's why they have the backup
camera it's just right there they don't
have to [__] turn around
all they got to do is move their eyes
they're big Fred Flintstone water head
can just sit there right
so anyways he's fat he's got this dog
and uh
and what it does is when we come walking
up the block
this it's it's on one side of the
driveway and the second it sees us it
immediately runs to the other side
waiting for us to come
and it's probably like you know whatever
like 20 feet between two and it just
[__] talks all this [__] all this
[__] [__] and my dog just looks at it
you know and it's such like
my dog doesn't even give a [__] I
actually react to the dog now like it's
been bugging me
I'll take a little short step towards it
a growl at it
I do other [__] like put my arms up you
know like you're supposed to do when
there's a bear coming at you
which I'm sure doesn't work
put your arms up so you look uh bigger
yeah well my where my arms are up I
don't look bigger than a bear so I mean
I don't see what the big [__] if I was
gonna step on an ant and it [__] put
four of its legs in the air well it
stood on two of them I'd be like wow
it's a very talented ant smoosh right
isn't that what the Bear's gonna do
thank you
I love those people with theories what
to do
what to do if you're in the water with a
shark swim underneath it they don't like
the vulnerable underside of their bodies
oh is that what I'm going to do I'm just
casually swim underneath it and it that
thing that can swim 10 times faster than
me
do you know how good a fighter you are
when you just use your mouth
think about that that thing's not
worried about taking any sort of [__]
you know imagine if you just fought with
your mouth you just [__] you know
kind of what if you just put your arms
out like they were fence you come down
by your waist so you just turn your
hands out like they would fit how many
bar fights do you think you'd win
all right when was the last time you saw
a bear loose in a bar fight
what if a shark could go in a bar you
think it would ever lose just say it
could breathe right you give it some
sort of reverse oxygen mask it was like
full of water
you know and you sit at the end of the
bar right and your [__] lady just
can't stop looking at the shark down
there right and then you're like well
you're [__] looking at this guy all
night what are you making me a [__]
jerk off and then you went down there
you know how many punches do you think
you'd get in he [__] eat it he'd eat
your goddamn hand
all right so [__] your hole you know put
your arms up to make yourself look
bigger curl up in a ball play dead
you know you only got one option
okay hope you're near other humans and
run near them and hope they don't see
what's chasing you and maybe they get
eaten
that's the move
that's the [__] move
you never go in the woods by yourself
all right you always want to go into the
woods with somebody that can't run as
fast as you and looks a lot tastier
okay that's called the buddy system
all right and I don't do a lot of scuba
diving because everybody knows I'm
terrified of the ocean but I would think
that that would be the same case
when you like if I was scuba diving
I'm trying to think which one of my
friends looks like a seal
[Laughter]
uh Joe to Rosa looks like an eel
sort of like an old eel you know it's
got a little bit of a punch
oh God who else I don't [__] I'm
gonna stuck this [__] whatever I
would I'd pick somebody there's got to
be somebody I know
somebody I know that looks like a walrus
although you know walrus can kill a
polar bear
God knows we've all seen that right
and Paul you're must seen that famous
YouTube video with that polar bear just
rather than picking on a little one he
went for the Thanksgiving dinner and
went for that big one the big one with
the giant [__] teeth it didn't even
look like got him that bad and the polar
bear just it was like a [__] he got
shanked and that was it
[__] thing like walked off I thought
it was just like regrouping like all
right that wasn't worth it maybe I'll
live to fight another day and it didn't
it just kind of walked away
only about 50 yards and just laid down
curled up in a ball
and uh just bled out and died I felt
really bad for it too
it's weird how you know you [__] look
at a polar bear just attacking walruses
you like
it's so vicious and everything that you
[__] hate the thing but then the
second you see it vulnerable you
actually kind of feel bad for it
like you guys ever seen that YouTube
video where that that pride of lions are
attacking I don't know one of those
bulls or whatever the [__] it is
and one of them gets kicked in the jaw
and it breaks its jaw
and its mouth is just hanging open like
you have a Roger Ebert right before he
died that [__] awful cancer he had
that's what this lion looked like right
just sitting there and how can I have
his mouth opened
and it was trying to play it off but
like all the other lions were eating and
this thing wasn't eating it was getting
skinnier and skinnier and they're just
looking at them
like dude just you know
either say it or shut your [__] mouth
it was just
and the thing just basically starved to
death and you felt bad you felt bad for
this thing
that would have no problem just eating
you alive actually you don't eat your
life they [__] go right for your
throat the worst thing is if you ever
got [__]
I'd say a Komodo dragon will they just
bite you
and then just [__] follow you around
for two days and wait for you to die
because the kind of bacteria that's in
their mouth once it gets in your
bloodstream you know you're just done
two days and they just sort of linger
around you just wait this thing's just
waiting to eat you
you're sitting there talking to you
[__] it's just walking behind
you like Jason you know Crystal Lake no
matter how fast you run that [__]
thing it's just
Lumber and alone behind you I would just
pick up rocks and just I would Stone it
to death you know
like what you know I don't know like
somebody who steals an iPod in Saudi
Arabia like what they have to [__]
deal with I would treat the lizard the
same [__] way
I would just I'd be all right
something's eating me but not you
[__] you're not gonna enjoy this
meal all right
I think I would be a delicacy out there
as pasty as I am
you know God knows everybody likes to
for [__] breast meat now that's why
they inject those chickens with all the
steroids they can't even walk because
they got such big [__] you know
breasteses now
um I'm talking about all right this is
the Monday Morning podcast everybody
I do this every single week if you're
new to it and I'm doing it a little bit
early this week you know why because my
[__] lady she's downstairs
she's watching the Oscars she's watching
the pre-red carpet Oscars and every year
you know I try to hang in there you know
it's like all right I know this is your
Super Bowl I said not watching much of
this as I [__] can
and you know I can only get so far you
know it was really interesting at one
point
was the guy uh who's hosting Daniel Day
Lewis whatever his name is Greg Odin
Kirk I don't know what the [__] his name
is
Thomas see Thomas Howell
Thomas Hayden Church it's one of those
three name guys it's Doogie Howser the
[__] his name
I had it
I had it anyways he was talking to this
other gay guy right and I felt like the
other gay guy was like the old style gay
guy and
the new guy
I gotta look up his [__] name it's
gonna ruin this story
it's gonna ruin this [__] story I
love when they ask the guys what are you
wearing
you know we're all wearing tuxedos does
it [__] matter
you know what are you wearing ah it's
Tom Ford oh my God I knew it was Tom
Horton top four yeah actually it's Mr
Tux
all right you dumb [__]
uh
I like how Ryan Seacrest has his own
line of [__] clothes that's hilarious
to me
Doogie Howser what is his [__] name
Doogie Howser all right MD Wikipedia
here we go
Neil Patrick Harris
I knew that so anyways he's talking to
this other gay dude right and I felt
like the other gay dude is let me ask
gay guys any gay guys who listen to this
is there a such thing as hacky gay or is
there a kind of gay that [__] annoys
you on television there's got to be you
know I mean there's a kind of redhead
that bugs me you know what I mean that
oh shucks guy tagging along with the
[__] Fonzarelli guy at what point was
Richie Cunningham going to be like hey
you know Fozzy you're kind of a [__]
you know you're banging everything that
move you're not that tough I'm [__]
taller than you
you might kick my ass but I'll get one
in I wanted to do a whole [__] five
ten seasons of that he never did it so
the other the pudgy gay guy
like he was going he was like that
really affected gay like
gay dude just going like uh
going to Neil Patrick Harris he was
going like um is there anybody in the
crowd that you're just like excited to
say
you like those gay guys that say honey
right it's like isn't that like hacky
gay because The Punchy guy goes is there
anybody you're excited to say like for
me it'd be Liza Minnelli and I just went
like really would it really be Liza
Minnelli
wasn't that like funny for a gay guy to
say like 30 [__] years ago come on
right
yeah but it just seemed like what's his
face
Neil Patrick Harris he had like you know
he was a [__] human being
the other guy was just [__] I don't
know what he was doing it was like he
was uh uh who was in that [__] movie
with that guy who hung himself I can't
remember I can't even remember the name
of the movies
you know what I mean
just because you're gay doesn't mean
you're not a person you know what I mean
it's almost like
somebody's acting regular and then all
of a sudden they become a game show host
and then they just stop being human they
just become game show host guy all right
let's spin the whale
I feel like when when gay dudes that's
like the gay version of doing that
I just want to shake that fat guy and
just be like who are you really
how do what what do you really talk like
um anyways I'm sure someone will [__]
take a snippet of that and send it to uh
we've had enough of that.com and next
thing you know there'll be another story
out there but that's what they do and
you know what you should do that you
should take this podcast seriously God
damn it
the nerve of me to be out here joking
around
okay this isn't my part it's your
podcast and you should take it seriously
and somehow shape it into whatever
[__] cause you're trying to get an
attention to
um anyway so she's down there watching
these these [__]
I don't know what the hell they I really
hope somebody gay chimes in on that
because I gotta I got a sense that I'm
[__] right on that one
you know what I mean
anyways
going back so Nia's downstairs and she's
just totally into it and somebody's
walking the red carpet she's just going
oh my God
no I can't stand
I can't sounds like it was a bad call
but she's actually that's like how into
the dresses she gets
and I sit there going Bill don't ruin it
don't ruin it okay just let her
enjoy this you watch sports it's just as
[__] stupid if you really sit down
and think about it it's just is [__]
stupid
it's just as stupid all right and I get
more [__] upset about the outcome
than she does with the Oscars I think
you know what I actually had to walk
away from the Oscars at one point they
were like you know all the best pictures
all of them are starring men
you know like every [__] award show
is that no well what the [__]
well can't that just mean that guys made
better movies this year
you can't say that can you you got to be
like no no no The Witches of Eastwick
that was [__] phenomenal
Witches of Eastwick really I don't watch
movies so [__] you what do you want from
me it's just every goddamn time
every time I swear to God best lemonade
stand hey how come there isn't anybody
from Bangladesh in this you know what
are you trying to suggest they don't
like lemonade
no I wasn't thinking about it I was just
making lemonade
um anyways
let's let's get to the [__]
I'm gonna blame my cold for how dumb I
sound this week this is like extra dumb
extra dumb
man you're out of your mind if you don't
do that one well I mean you know if you
like to shop
if you're into shopping you can do that
I went to the mall yesterday it was a
[__] show
absolute [__] show but you know what the
icing on the cake was they were selling
Girl Scout cookies
you know
they should always snot always sell to
Girl Scout cookies every they should
bring it back more than once a year
though
make those trips to the mall a little
more exciting all right meandies
everybody here we go can I sing I'll
have to do this differently my raspy
voice who do I sound like you'll never
find
that's a hacky Lou roll song I like lady
love way better
your love is sweeter than the Summer
Breeze I got puberty you know I swear
all right
meandis 90 me undies meandies no more
sweaty balls
me undies you don't have to wear them at
the mall cause you went to [__] Trunk
Club all you got to do is grab your
underwear in the door you slip them on
in your balls aren't wet that's all you
[__] get oh yeah when you wear
[__] me undies woohoo they're making
poor ladies too
her clam will only be wet because of you
bam all right 90 that's the percent of
your life you're in your underwear and
underwear gets old fast you know the
feeling of putting on old saggy
underwear you need to know the feeling
of great fitting underwear that's two
times softer than cotton I gotta tell
you everybody's raving about this
anybody I know on my podcast when they
send me a tweet that they ordered me
undies all they talk about is how great
their balls feel
the guy less annoying your boss would be
if your balls felt that nice and dry
you need to know about me myundies.com
who wants to get yelled at wearing saggy
underwear it's like you're losing on two
fronts it's like Hitler you know when he
went too far into [__] Russia myundis
is the most comfortable underwear you
will ever wear and it's insane how good
they make you feel they fit perfectly
they'll ride up on you and they
literally pull moisture away from you
it's gross from your skin so you stay
cool I have mine on right now you know
what I actually do
I [__] love them
they come in superhero colors too uh
they have cool styles for both men and
women and they look great check out the
photos yourself meundies.com this
quality would typically retail for two
times the meundy's price I would love to
talk to an expert in underwear to
actually see if that claim is true
I mean what is two times what is the
price of underwear who knows it's like
that old George Bush how much is eggs I
don't [__] know I'm the president I
have a chef
too busy trying to make sure nobody
shoots missiles out of [__] [__]
how many missiles does Russia have well
all right then you worry about the eggs
can you do me a favor no and just
[__] audit that guy
all right sorry no retail middlemen
means more savings for you here I'll
make it easy go to meundies.com and get
20 off your first order
and free shipping save even more when
you buy a pack of them they guarantee
you're going to be happy with your first
pair or your first pair is free
well if I'm not happy does it make a
difference on the price
I [__] hate this underwear oh and
it's free all right
I love this woman well you know she
doesn't have a clap okay
all right dead legalism right okay one
more read all right let's get back to
the podcast
all right so what else oh for those of
you out there that want to email me uh
the email for the podcast is Bill at the
mm podcast once again that email is Bill
at the mm podcast
yes and also I've been getting a bunch
of emails about people who did that swap
test thing there to see if you could be
a bone marrow donor or a blood donor
sorry
uh here's one hey Billy blood donor I'm
not looking to get read on the podcast
but I wanted to tell you that I joined
uh be the match.org because I heard you
talk about it on the show it sounds like
a great organization I hope you followed
through with signing up I haven't yet I
gotta do it
and then the obligatory thanks and go
swab yourself there you go
um I have to do that I have to do
something positive with my [__] life
are you like me
are you a [__] drunk go do something
positive go to be the match.org
have him swab your mouth you know then
you'll be a match you'll save somebody's
life that's funny I would save
somebody's life and they'd also get
slightly buzzed
and it boost back
um
all right I uh
I've gotten back into reading everybody
and by reading
I mean I just I just like reading
autobiographies right now I'm reading
this
actually the book about Richard Pry that
was [__] amazing that I started I'm
you know I got add so I'm always reading
like two three at a time so reading that
the ESPN book uh those guys are having
too much fun and I'm also tearing
through Stephen Adler my favorite
drummer
from the 80s I just I [__] I don't
know
I absolutely love the way he played
um and he's got a book called uh my
Appetite for Destruction sex drugs and
guns and roses and uh it's really cool
is if you already read slasher's book
to hear him go over like some of the
same stories in his version I mean they
line up pretty good but uh
I know it's pretty it's pretty [__]
awesome he actually talks about some
[__] that
I had no idea it happened to him and uh
made me have even more empathy for that
guy you know what I watched recently
this week
was
um
they actually I never knew this I was
literally like two things devastated me
like two major blows one was more severe
because it was a death of somebody but
in 1990 as far as a music fan
it was the first obviously the top of
the list was when Stevie Ray Vaughan
died I couldn't [__] but that was the
first time
um
someone that I was into to that level
uh died and just
it was just so [__] shocking like I
didn't even uh
you know it didn't register until after
you know then family style came out with
Jimmy Vaughn so there was still new
material
and I just remember thinking like wow
there's gonna be no more Stevie Ray
Vaughan and double trouble new material
and he kind of had this this theme where
he would always
with a lot of his albums he would start
with an instrumental and end with an
instrumental so I'd always be excited
when I bought his new album
to um
would he do that or wouldn't he maybe he
did it on a few
getting older starting from a rude mood
but I think was the first song on the
second side
well I guess he would have one
instrumental every album or two wait
he had Stang Swang and couldn't stand
the weather and scuttlebutton he had
rude mood on Texas Flood
it's say what unsold the soul he had
Riviera Paradise oh he also had Lenny
how can I forget that one so anyways I
was always thinking like oh man in this
plane always will go to the next level I
just remember thinking like wow that's
never going to happen again so there was
that and then
um
Stephen Adler got kicked out of Guns and
Roses
and I couldn't [__] believe it
it was just he was he was the guy for me
like I was
all about all these other guys from the
80s that I saw you know and they all had
the double bass drum set up and all that
I just remember when I saw
guns and roses live at The Ritz on MTV
and I saw all the music that Stephen
Adler was getting out of that little
four-piece drum kit and it was so
[__] cool to just go see somebody go
back to having the one rack Tom with
just a one ride symbol
and this is how dumb I am when it really
comes to spatial relations and [__] like
I'm really [__] in the head like I
don't that's why I don't have a good
Mechanical Mind even like when they say
if there's cooking directions like
you know
turn on the front burner when I look at
the stove the front burner is not the
burner closest to me it's the one
furthest away to me I always view the
stove like I'm standing behind a car and
that's I don't know why that doesn't
make any [__] sense but I'm always
looking at [__] ass backwards so at the
time I had a five piece slingerland late
70s all bottom sizes 24 like 14 by 24
bass drum
I think I had a 12 14 and a 16.
you know two racks of the floor and
I had my ride up high
over the second rack Tom and
I was telling the guy at work he's like
yeah man I really want to play a fork
that's how dumb I was I really want to
play a four piece but you know I got a
five piece kit man maybe next kid I'll
buy will be a four piece and he goes
well why don't you just take that other
Tom off and then it becomes a four piece
and I was like oh yeah
do you know how bad I want that story
not to be true but it is true so I took
that [__] rack Tom off
and it changed my world
as far as drum and how much fun it was
and I've never gone back
I absolutely love that setup because the
way it makes you go around the kit is
totally different
because once people started having the
two rack Toms it became start you fill
in the snare
go up to the first rack Tom and then
just blow down every [__] time you
had and every fill kind of started to
sound the same
but when you had the [__] sort of the
L-shaped thing going there one up and
one to the you know one straight up and
one over to the right it made you go
around the kit differently I mean
nowadays I don't even think kids can
relate to that [__] because there's so
much information on YouTube and kids
compete with each other that the the
growth of the average drummer is through
the [__] roof like
in the last five years how good people
have gotten at playing at drums compared
to five years when I was a kid it's not
even close
um
and now you know they had the bass drums
in with the fills and all that they're
just [__] they're they're
unbelievable
you know but whatever so
that was my thing you know I started off
playing with to AC DC records and then
Rolling Stones so it's Phil Rudd Charlie
Watts really simple two four [__] and
then
um moving up to to Appetite for
Destruction
which was all you know rock and roll
type of [__] but you know bass drum was
more busier
and uh he had he had signature licks and
that type of thing but the degree of
difficulty as far as just technically
was harder for me and I used to play
that I got stripped it down to the four
piece I used to play that [__] album
every day
after work man I would I would unload
trucks all day in this Warehouse laugh
my balls off
one of the great jobs I ever had you
know
and then I would uh
I would [__] go home
lift weights this is my day lift weights
I go on a bike ride
and then I [__] uh then I would sit
down and play drums and that was it I
would just [__]
play from the first song all the way to
the end of the album
and my older brother used to drive him
[__] nuts because I sucked and but
Steve what was funny was Steven's drum
parts were so unique to each song that
in his head he knew all of the tracks he
knew what what's if he came home in the
middle of the album
he'd be like ah [__] he's only on Mr
Brownstone he's only on the
he's only like he's only halfway through
the first side of the [__] tape you
know it was funny is I had the tape in a
boom box I didn't even have headphones I
should have got headphones and I didn't
I could have heard it so much better I
would have that thing [__] cranked up
and I'd have my head turned to the side
with this little shitty plastic [__]
poor excuse for a bum box and I used to
play that thing uh
all the [__] time
I remember just and you had no idea you
just had to figure [__] out for yourself
there was no YouTube you just listened
to it and I was convinced anytime any
drama was playing on the snare drum it
was never just singles with accents I
always was convinced it was some sort of
rudiment he's got to be playing a
rudiment it sounds too cool and um
I guess a single stroke role is a
rudiment but you know what I mean I
thought it was some sort of special
sticking so I remember it's so easy in
the beginning when he's got those fast
16th notes on the snare drum with the
with the crash accents I thought he was
playing Paradise so I would be trying to
crash and play paradiddles it was oh my
God it was a [__] show until [__]
somebody at this other Warehouse is
burnout musician he he showed me that it
was singles
and uh I don't know that was just a
great it was a great time in my life as
far as like
um
I was [__] up bad
but like it was going to be a while
before the chickens were going to come
home to roost because it was still in my
early 20s
I was [__] up in college but nobody I
knew had graduated college so even
though I was behind
you know none of them had jobs yet I
hadn't started doing stand-up
I was working out like a [__] it was the
best shape I was ever in I lifted
weights every [__] day and rode a
bike like 11 miles every day you know
the weekends I one day I'd ride it 18
miles
and I was like 20 years old and I had
like zero body fat I was like ah and I
would go out and booze like [__] four
nights in the week eat McDonald's at the
end of the night these are just
metabolism it was the best and I went to
work and my job was unloading trucks
that's all it was
and then stalking the shelves
and I were everybody I worked with was a
[__] either it was a warehouse they
were either class clowns struggling
musicians or some sort of just
I don't know drug addict free spirit it
was just the best [__] group of
people I ever worked with and um
anyways
I remember
um
somewhere yeah I always heard they
played Farm Aid
I remember hearing a story like it went
Nationwide I think because MTV was right
that's right
was axel said that someone in this band
is [__] with Mr Brownstone when they
opened up for uh
the Rolling Stones and I was like oh wow
that's cool they're living just like
that song I didn't know that that was a
bad sign for the band and then
um
I don't know if they played Farm Aid or
whatever and I just heard I'd you know I
heard that he got fired and I couldn't
[__] believe it
and I never thought the band was the
same once he left and Izzy left and then
they got
they got all those other guys they added
a [__] keyboard thing and it just the
whole thing just like
yeah you know what happened so
um anyways this is a long drawn-out
story but I didn't realize that oh
that uh there's video of Stephen Adler's
last performance with Guns and Roses
and uh Slash tells a story that Stephen
was high
and they went out to go perform and he
went to jump on the the drum riser
but his death perception was off because
of whatever he was on and he missed it
by like eight feet and he does he comes
out and he [__] just eats it does a
face plant then he gets behind the drums
and evidently he didn't really know what
songs they were going to be doing I
don't know
that was his fault or whatever
so they did Civil War
and you see the look on his face in the
video like what the [__] I've been I've
rehearsed this with the band but never
with Axel but dude that is it me he
[__] kills it
I mean they're all a little bit sloppy
but I thought he did fine and then they
pulled out some punk tune
and Duff had to count it off for him but
even then he still [__] did a great
job
and it made me Matic all over again that
they fired him but like I'm getting
through his book and I think uh
obviously they wouldn't have got rid of
him if he wasn't completely [__] up
but um it's weird to read this book
because I know how it ends as far as his
trip with Guns and Roses but I'm still
[__] rooting for the guy like that's
how big a fan I am of his so all right
there's your drumner part of the [__]
podcast for this week so anyway so I'm
reading that [__]
and um
oh here's one for you I wanted to read
you this [__]
all right
let me type this in here
people always say this [__] like dude
you're type A you're type a right like
this is some negative [__] thing
um
oh yeah type B and all that here's
here's what next time somebody says
that's because people usually what they
do when they run out of points to make
with you they say oh you're type A
you're type a right
rather than being like no I made some
good points and now you can't refute
them so now you're gonna you're gonna
[__] hide behind this [__] pop
psychology horseshit this is really
interesting to me uh type A and type B
personality theory
you hear the big word there Theory those
type A and type B personalities are just
theories
and it basically describes two
contrasting personality types that could
either raise or lower respectively one's
chances of developing coronary heart
disease
there is a considerable controversy
about the role of these personality
types in coronary heart disease and the
role of the tobacco industry funding of
early research in this area early
research turns out they funded this
study for 40 years and basically
the theory about the tobacco industry is
what they were trying to do
is cover up the fact that cigarette
smoking
caused heart disease
and they tried to blame it more on
if you were this type a guy who gets
impatient with people that's goal driven
that loses his temper and all that like
you you had a bigger change like that
was more of a cause of the heart disease
than smoking than if you were actually
like more chilled and relaxed like a
type B personality you wouldn't get
heart disease so
as far as my ignorant way of reading
this like these personalities are just
like
because I feel like everything that they
bring up I am
like type A describes individuals as
rigidly organized I'm not my office is a
[__] show and I don't write anything
down and I never look at emails
highly status conscious
yeah I mean I drive a Prius and I dress
like Malcolm Young I don't give a [__]
uh sensitive yes impatient yes take on
more than they can handle I got like 20
Hobbies Maybe
want other people to get to the point
who doesn't
anxious
not as much as I used to be proactive
depends on what you're talking about and
concerned with time management who wants
to waste their [__] time
um all right type B
by definition generally live at lower
stress levels and typically work
steadily enjoying achievement but not
becoming stressed when they do not
achieve
I mean I've kind of come to that point
I'm where I'm at you know I think that
just means being more happy with your
life you know what my comedian and I
sell tickets I mean what the [__] else
is there everything else after that is
gravy I felt like I made it like four
years ago after like uh somewhere
between
um
why do I do this and let it go
once I was selling the tickets at clubs
and I could go out twice a month live my
dream and live a comfortable lifestyle
take care of my wife what the [__] did I
care
laughs
so I don't know but anyways it's good to
know they're actually a [__] Theory
just a theory
you know something you know who probably
came up with this [__]
[__] jerk off stick up for yourself
quit coming up with this crap here's
funny white tobacco companies
further discrediting the so-called type
a behavior pattern a study from 2012
based on searching the legal tobacco
documents Library suggests the
phenomenon of initial Pro initially
promising results followed by negative
findings to be partially explained by
the tobacco industry's involvement
in the type A B personality research to
undermine the scientific evidence on
smoking and health
the industry's newest the industry's
interest in type A B person I lasted at
least four decades until the late 1990s
involving substantial funding to key
researchers encouraged to prove smoking
to Simply correlate with a personality
type prone to coronary heart disease and
cancer
so I don't know I find that interesting
after the 50th time somebody said I'm
Type A
let's just say it's not a theory I think
I have elements of type A and type B
I really think a type A type person
would will throw down in a bar
which I never did I never did that I I
haven't had a fight since like [__]
junior high and I lost I was playing
stick hockey and I lost to this [__]
guy
that was it it was over and I was just
like yeah that sucked
you know
just because you have a temper doesn't
mean you type a does it
only it does to me a type A is like a
[__] guys guy knows how to fix a car
or break your jaw to me that's Taipei
he's like a hero I think very few people
at Taipei
and type B is the whole you know
either living like this Zen
I think there's there's two ways to live
in both if they actually exist okay
you could beat type A
this is Zen way maybe to live both I
don't know cause like there's the type B
person actually knows how to fight
but recognizes how stupid it is
and doesn't throw down unless they have
to and then they throw down and they win
and in the end they still think it's
stupid
that person does that person exist or am
I just thinking about a cool guy saw in
a movie
speaking of that do you guys see the
movie The Drop
I saw a bunch of movies
in my 70 plus hours of airline travel
over the last uh month
but the drop is a great [__] movie
James gandolfini's last movie and
there's another actor in there of course
I didn't get his name I was on the plane
um
I can't I don't know I I gotta I gotta
get his [__] name here so I'll [__]
this up
I absolutely love that guy's performance
in that thing
really cool movie come on
it dropped 2014.
um
would it be great if I actually looked
this up in the meantime as I'm waiting
for this to come around
I saw Horrible Bosses too which I
thought was [__] hilarious
did you see uh anybody else see that
movie
anybody
um
sedakis was [__] hilarious is it Tom
Hardy
is that who it is
Jesus Christ he looks so different in
every [__] picture yeah that's the
guy
Tom Hardy was the [__]
in the drop
he was so [__] good in that movie
um Horrible Bosses too I [__] love
that but Kevin Spacey's [__]
hilarious in it
Charlie day uh Sudeikis all three of
those guys Justin Bieber just funny ass
[__] movie it's laughing like an
[__] on the plane everybody looking
at me and I didn't care because I had
another 10 hours to go and I was
drinking the [__]
Johnny Walker black there
I saw Dumb and Dumber too
was disappointed there was a couple of
really good scenes but I was
disappointed
I didn't think that the script was there
for the those guys that's obviously a
[__] classic
um
what else did I see I think I told you I
saw a chef a while back when I was when
I was in New Zealand I saw a chef
what a [__] great move let me ask you
this as John Leguizamo ever been bad
that guy he's been in bad movies but he
he always makes the movie better as long
as he's [__] in it it's over
if it's a great script he's great if the
movie stinks he's still great the guy's
[__] money in the bank
money that's probably why he's been
working for like 30 [__] years he's
unbelievable
um
it was that fitting that I'm talking
about this [__] on Oscar night everybody
as you don't watch this many movies I
usually don't fly this much
I usually don't talk this much I usually
don't start sentences with I usually
every [__] two seconds let me get
back to what the [__] I was talking
about here
um
what the hell is it
what was I going to talk about those
Bruins huh
beating the Blackhawks
uh by four goals how'd you like that
Chicago
what's up uh Vancouver Calgary
Edmonton St Louis that's who we lost to
on this trip already brutal [__]
losses I got all my tape uh I don't have
the nerve to watch the Calgary game I
watched the uh the St Louis one I was
really jet lagged last week so
everybody I went to Vancouver and
Calgary but I watched the St Louis one
um
we called up suban was probably the
wrong team to do it some people said who
gives a [__] he'll be fine
um but I can't imagine why are we trying
to get rid of tucum
you know guys had a little bit of a
rough patch all of a sudden what he's
not good anymore
it's his [__] fault we lost all these
great defensemen
it's been all these injuries we lost uh
[__] boy Chuck I mean come on you're
gonna blame him
stupid that's like what you know what
that's dude does [__] like that New York
does that Boston does it too it's so
[__] dumb
you know every two [__] years the
goddamn giant fans try to get rid of
their coaching [__] Eli Manning it's
like Oh you mean those Super Bowl
champions yeah I'm sure it's their fault
um
what else I think that's it I got it too
I watched the end of the Daytona 500. I
got to go to that one of these years
you owe it to yourself someday I've
never been to NASCAR I've been to two
Indy 500 races but
you owe it to yourself at some point to
go to any sort of auto racing event
because the funniest [__] thing about
it is the difference in intellect
between what's going on in the pit row
and what's going on in the [__]
stance
it's unbelievable
I mean you're talking state of the art
like Mega brains trying to figure out
how to go half a second faster
tenth of a second faster like 200 miles
an hour so you went by a [__] bumper
right
and then literally you look across the
street
which is the track
and there's some guy [__] just
crushing Old Milwaukee
you know would dip in his mouth he's so
fat his T-shirt can't cover his navel
that's what I loved and I you know I
would love to say at the Indy 500 you
know Open Wheel racing that was a little
more snooty it wasn't
you could bring a cooler in
you could do whatever the [__] you
wanted it was a great time and uh I've
been meaning
to go to Talladega and Daytona I got to
scratch those off the bucket list at
some point I always forget it's just
NASCAR starts at such a weird time
it's a great time to go right no
football
this is the time of year I always get
into like college hoop like I didn't
realize Kentucky was still undefeated so
I've been watching I just hate the
[__] pac-10
I like watching Kansas Kentucky
and I like to uh tobacco row man I like
[__] uh Carolina Duke NC State I like
watching that [__] it just sucks the Big
East is gone now at least back in the
day man the 80s when I first started
watching [__] hoop the ACC and the
[__] Big East
like in a five-year period I watched
like James Worthy
uh Michael Jordan
Patrick Ewing Ralph Sampson
Elijah won and what's his face Clyde
Drexler were out in Houston Chris Mullen
was St John's Pearl Washington it's
Syracuse I mean it was just [__]
every week there was some sort of
[__]
epic goddamn battle
always would come down to the end
those great coaches I forget the coach
for St John's always wearing the Cosby
sweaters
then he had John Thompson who was as big
as [__] Ewing almost
I always wondered like how [__] long
is his tie
that it goes all the way down to almost
his belt buckle when that [__] he was
like six foot ten it's like where the
[__] do you get your suits made
you know
just picture like the the Haberdashery
guy like they like elves like standing
on the ladders trying to measure the guy
um
yeah and he had what's his face
uh oh my God am I gonna forget his name
Dean Smith
I told you guys all these [__]
stories about going to the dean Dome
seeing Michael Jordan play I told you
that
as an NBA player
right before the Charlotte the year
before the Charlotte Hornets came they
tried to get NBA excitement going on
down in North Carolina
so they scheduled uh two NBA scrimmages
during the summer time
before the NBA season probably like in
September and I went to both games
and each NBA team had a former Tar Heel
on it so it's the Chicago Bulls Michael
Jordan no championships still had hair
still was skinny didn't bulk up because
Detroit hadn't beat him up enough right
I saw him play uh
who was it I think the Cleveland
Cavaliers that had uh Brad Doherty
I think his name was he's that guy with
the [__] hairline that went right
down to his eyebrows who'd actually now
he actually commentates for uh
stock car racing and then I saw the
Lakers with James Worthy magic karimo I
think Kareem didn't show up though
he's too old at that point like man
ain't [__] coming down for that [__]
he might have been retired it was 87
summer of 87.
um yeah he didn't play 87-88 did he I
don't [__] know and then they played
the Cavaliers they had Sam Perkins
that's right anyways let me uh let me
[__] read some of the letters for the
goddamn we can't before
before I [__]
go off the rails here all right
um
okay here we go
Alpha Brain
build a half a Man Thrill Ride ah go
[__] yourself I know your buddy buddy
with Joe Rogan and I'm not sure if he's
already turned you on to onto this but
his company on it pronounced on it thank
you
oh you know what I think I already knew
it was on it I wouldn't have known
I wouldn't know how to say it anyways
produce a product called Alpha Brain
which helps with cognitive brain
function
he's been talking about it for years but
tried it a couple of months ago and it's
great it helped me focus on a novel I'm
writing
on nights and weekends
on nights and weekend away from my
boring day job weekends away from my
boring day job that's why you should
have written it uh you always talk about
how you forget stuff enough trouble
concentrating you should give it a shot
and report back to us I'm sure he'd give
you some free samples thanks and go [__]
yourself ah yeah I don't [__] with drugs
other than boost I just don't
you know hey
see that try to do a solid thought she
was downstairs
um
yeah I'll [__] around with Miracle drugs
if I have a disease I'll do that like
look being scatterbrained is working out
for me
it does it just churns more comedy I
just [__] up and I embarrass myself
you know
it's like didn't you ever see that
episode of Taxi where they showed
Reverend Jim before he [__] ate the
pot brownies it was just some boring guy
with the sweater on
if I took Joe Rogan's pills and all of a
sudden I started focusing more
than what I what I would just
I don't think you'd like me
no I don't [__] with pills
I don't [__] with pills I don't take I
don't take sleeping pills
you know I don't [__] with them I think
they beat up your liver I think it's a
bunch of [__] out there that they say is
healthy and it doesn't have side effects
and I feel like the Food and Drug
Administration has you know I've seen
documentaries
where people used to work for these drug
companies are now they've infiltrated
the food uh the whatever the [__] it's
called I just said it
uh who's a better candidate for this
[__] than me
the fruit Food and Drug organization
Food and Health whatever the [__] it is
I just said it I just had it it's
unbelievable
the FDA there you go
you got the nuts running the nut house
so they just pushing [__] through
clearing you know they're getting
Kickbacks on the side I don't [__]
trust any of it all right
I think the way I was born is natural
you know I don't think being
scatterbrained
is neces it's bad as far as the way
things are set up right now
but back in the day if we were still
living in the woods I'd be [__]
killing it I'd have those squirrel-like
instincts so I'd [__] be looking
around you know
but it's just weirds people out in the
office environment
I'm all right with it I'm staying with
the with how I am
all right
I saw Joe the other night
I had one of my best sets of the [__]
year up at the ice house man I just had
a great time
I saw Joe the other night and I got to
tell you something
that man had laser focus when he was
talking to me
he didn't break eye contact once so
maybe that [__] works I have no idea
I ain't taking any drugs man I do enough
to I do enough [__] damage to myself
last thing I need to do does that make
any sense though
I'm playing devil's advocate here oh my
God I can't [__] think oh take this
pill and then now you can think straight
all right and that's it
that's it right
those side effects no nothing I just
take this and magically I'm fixed
I don't know about that there always
seems to be like this like back in the
day old school [__] like penicillin like
[__] like that seemed to work but all
this [__] since then I feel like the the
drugs like
they just sort of peaked at some point
you know
and there was no more new drugs to kind
of come up with unless they they fix
something while [__] something else
up
like Rogaine right
you put that [__] on your head you grow
a little bit of hair and then your kid
has like three feet you know or whatever
your heart starts racing there was
always something can't I be cake and eat
it this is what I'm gonna let it's a
brand new drug I'm gonna let all you
guys take it all right and if 10 years
from now you still have laser focus
all right
and your livers are fine then maybe I'll
think about doing it but at that point
I'll be uh
I'll be pushing 60.
so what the [__] do I care when I'm
pushing 60 that's what I'm gonna start
thinking like what am I going to feel
like I can try heroin only once I'm
gonna do that
I'm gonna smoke it
you know
not [__] with you I shouldn't say
that this you know
people actually give me [__] about that
I would never [__] try that how many
[__] people got it uh
that's bad this week to bring that [__]
up so I'm not gonna anyways that's the
trouble with improv all right
girlfriends breath stinks
dear Billington the red
uh I've been I've been seeing my
girlfriend for a little over a year now
and if you can tell me your [__]
breath has stunk the entire time I'm
really not gonna have any sympathy for
you
and I don't know how you [__] bring
it with the only way you bring it up now
is if you act like it just started
I've been seeing my girlfriend for a
little over a year now we're very much
in love and have a great time when we're
around each other however in the past
couple of months I've noticed every so
often her breath stinks
I'm not talking she ate something bad
but some deep-seated stench that makes
my eyebrow hair burn away I noticed that
her teeth have a certain yellow tint to
them
that is hard to look away from it's like
a film of American cheese oh Jesus sorry
for the grossest but that's just the
truth it's not like she doesn't take
care of herself she's very beautiful and
responsible anyway she has health
insurance but not Dental it hasn't been
to a dentist in three years well take
her
taker okay because she's starting to
sound
like a woman that lives in a tree in a
[__] fable
um I think she might have some build up
of tartar or gum disease yeah or
something she needs a deep cleaning to
start with and then they should if that
doesn't work I would check for some sort
of sinus infection
you know if that doesn't work uh
you know I don't know
consult a specialist rather than a
comedian doing a podcast
um
we're going to move out together when I
go to my new job and I'm going to pay
for dental insurance when I make the
money because everyone should be able to
see a dentist especially as a girls ask
for her until that day comes I want to
say something but don't know how to say
it obviously I just can't say honey your
mouth smells like [__] we're very open
with each other all the time but I can't
get the balls to tell her to say this
any suggestion from you or the lovely
new would be appreciated all right ah
[__] I got to get Nia in here for this
one
hang on
hey Nia
Nia
can you help me on the podcast
I need you to help me answer a question
because I can only think of a way to say
it in a mean way
I just
stand shut up
pressing pause and coming to get me
instead of screaming oh I have [__] to
do a crazy person I have [__] to do what
do you want I'm watching something all
right here we go this guy's girlfriend's
breath stinks okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
go through it really quickly
how you ate garlic today no I didn't
really because I had a sore throat ate
raw garlic and then you wash it down
with milk how gross is that to [__]
yeah I know
to somehow fixes your sore throat I
don't know is it working no and I feel
like I [__] ate a a lit cigarette
um anyways I'm just gonna say it real
quick because you only have one
microphone so anyways her breath didn't
stink and now all of a sudden lately
it's just stinking she's noticing a film
across her teeth kind of yellowish she
hasn't um seen a dentist in like three
years how does he how does he say listen
I love you but your breath stinks I want
to pay for you to go to a dentist I I
don't want you walking around the world
you know you're going to get a nickname
like that's how bad your breath smells
does she not brush her teeth
no she does but she hasn't been to a
dentist and why she says takes care she
might have some tartar built up the
first thing you do is go brushes her
teeth every day and she still has all
this going on no we said there's a
yellow film yeah that means she's not
brushing her teeth because why would
there be a yellow film on her teeth if
she brushed her teeth in the morning and
then before she went to bed even if it's
once a day she needs to
go see how does he tell it how does he
get her to go to the dentist like okay
okay you know how would you say it to me
how no how would you want me to say it
to you if that's if that was going on
oh see can I practice one
let me practice one we all know you're
going to anyways just go ahead yes go
ahead hey Nia
no no you don't have to get up you can
sit right over there stay over there
um
I love you but sometimes I like looking
at you from across the room
listen I'm only telling you this because
I love you and I would want you to tell
me this it hasn't been
you know the whole time I've been with
you but at some point in the last six
weeks like
you've had like moments especially like
actually right now like I don't know
what's going on but your breath really
smells
bad
[Laughter]
and I
I don't want to be near you
[Laughter]
and it kills me to tell you this but
your breath stinks and I think you need
to go see a dentist I know you don't
have dental insurance and I want to pay
for it okay because you're too beautiful
to be walking around with that erotic
smell in your mouth
do you still love me
I wouldn't be mad at that because I
would stop if it were you saying that to
me I would laugh at it and I would know
that was coming from a good point you
would be mortified I would be mortified
though I would be really really
embarrassed but obviously you know if
anyone's going to tell me it's going to
be the person that has to kiss you and
be around you all the time so yeah well
then fix it fix what I just said how
should how can you tell it where a lady
wouldn't get pissed I don't know that's
actually not too bad I don't think you
know just
that's so hard I don't hey uh [__] mouth
why don't you go see a [__] dentist
before you kill the houseplants
all right go eat your pizza yeah I mean
I think that's it just be really just
brutally honest but try to do it in a
cute funny way
you know and just be like yeah oh God
that would be so hard yeah you're
beautiful you're too beautiful but
you're walking around
because at least you're throwing in a
compliment your body and face is a 10
your mouths are negative too
we got to get those numbers closer
together
how are we gonna do this
all right can you be fair can you give
me a glass of water my [__] I ran out
of water my throat is killing me
I sound like this woman's breath
um all right good luck with that sir all
right let's wrap this up
um
body weight exercises spelled b-o-o-d-y
booty weight exercises Willie Bonbon uh
I heard of the podcast last week you
like body weight exercise me too [__]
love them last year I found a great app
with a shitload of great bodyweight
routines it's called
is this the one app that you invented
this might be free advertisement I don't
care it's for working out uh body weight
training
you are your own gym I think it's about
three to three dollars and it's fan
[__] tastic it was developed by a
Navy SEAL fitness trainer and it has
four different 10-week programs for
different Fitness levels all the
workouts are short and will kick your
ass in a good way plus a bunch of other
goodies I can't recommend it highly
enough and I am not in any way
affiliated with the app it's just a
great workout at a great price no
equipment needed but I recommend picking
up a pull-up bar you stick in your door
frame for twenty thirty dollars at
Target or somewhere I started using it
back in September and in much better
shape because it because of it [__]
awesome dude uh while I'm at it I also
recommend a regular full body stretching
routine I've been doing that for months
as well and I'm as Limba as a who is
clam that's what he wrote Nia
a horse clam there and for the ladies
I'm as bendable as a drunken laos's Wick
whiskey dick there kid see that he was
trying to he's trying to do one for the
women
like a like a noodle deck you know when
there's no blood in a dick you can bend
it let me let me ask you if he's talking
about how great and how in shape he is
why would he ever compare himself to a
limp dick
women sucking the comedy out of
everything for over a hundred years off
all right take this what is it it's a
[__]
oh
Ricola
all right by the way in a recent study I
read about in health show that two best
the two best things you can do before
bed to get a good night's sleep is
stretch and visualize
um what are you jerking off after you
[__] touch your toes
I'm sorry
that's so [__] childish and I love it
so I often stretch and then do a guided
visual mental meditation
from YouTube before bed
what
doesn't mean you're watching a video
do you think I took it to a weird place
there I didn't these guided meditations
are corny but they're great super
relaxing
hope this is
info is useful to you and my fellow mmpc
brothers and sisters be well
um you know something
oh I think that makes a lot of sense I
might try that
oh you know what I used to do you know
when I was doing the helicopter lessons
which I'm going back to my final six in
March before I test for my license here
um
I was having problems with auto
rotations and I just sat there
visualizing doing them
but not closing my eyes I was just like
my minute at the end of the bed
pretending I was in there and the next
day I did them I was much better so
maybe there's something to that I have
no idea
he said uh be well
miniature version of animal dear build
okay miniature version of animal here we
go I think this is the last one here
[Music]
um
if you could have a smaller version of a
normally large animal what would it be
ideally it would be trained and you'd
have it as a pet
signed weird roommate
well it couldn't kill me
um
I love animals too much to have a make a
wild animal a pet
so
what would I have I'd have a miniature
version of my dog Cleo so even when it
flipped out when I dressed up like a
drummer I wouldn't have to worry about
it killing me that's a lame answer
I'd have a miniature gorilla
that's what I would have
miniature gorilla right then I do
pull-ups as it climbed a tree looking at
me like why can't you go all the way up
and I'd be like because I'm human
miniature gorilla the [__] wrong with
you then we'd smoke some weed man
that's a weed [__] question
man if you could if you could have any
animal
miniature what would you have
I'd have an alligator man and I'd have a
clip my toenails dude all right old
Billy red face first off go [__]
yourself second I'm having some issues
with my roommate I'm in college and
share a campus apartment with one
roommate my question is how do you
motivate someone to be more considerate
uh you can't I grew up in a house with
brothers and sisters so I try to respect
other people and those who I live with
for the most part my roommate on the
other hand doesn't do dishes doesn't
take out the garbage and doesn't even
change the toilet paper when we're out
of it I've asked him to do it do the
above mention nicely and he gave up on
it pretty quickly he doesn't even say
what's up or Mike eye contact when he
walks in the door I'm not trying to be a
douche but at what that what time do you
think I should take a [__] on his bed
now or later thanks
uh I don't think you need any help I
think you're mentally moving in the
right direction
you know there's got to be um
you don't have communal dishes right
then I'll start using yours uh you know
you're gonna have to drop this guy at
some point
this is what you do next time he doesn't
flush the toilet
I I would just stick his pillow in the
toilet I mean I think what else are you
gonna do
and then put his pillow back on the
[__] bed
I had a roommate like that
I had a roommate like that we almost
came to blows
and um
do when you're living with an animal you
live him with an animal and that's just
like you're just gonna have to tough it
out for the rest of the semester and get
somebody different
and um
is the deal
just know that some he's that's the type
of guy that's probably going to get
divorced or he's going to marry an
unbelievably understanding woman
um I [__] hate guys like that I I
never
that whole [__] you know you know
that stereotype of how on a guy's
apartment looks like there's a slice of
pizza between the cushions
[__] and I never was like that why
the [__] would you want to live like
that
never did that I remember when I was
living in New York right
um
I had this roommate and um
you know from day one
if I did you know if I dirtied some
dishes and he had a few in there I did
mine and I did his
you know if I took out the trash a
couple times in a row I didn't give a
[__] and you know what he immediately
was the same way I showed him respect he
showed me respect we got to look [__]
great
right I [__] move out
this other dude moves in and all of a
sudden all the harmony goes away he
starts telling what a [__] [__]
the other guy is
and I read it took me a while to realize
it's like no dude you were the [__]
[__] and you pissed this guy he was a
respectful guy if he showed him respect
he took out the trash too without asking
he'd actually hook you up took me a
minute to figure out the math on that
one so you just got a bad roommate and
when you live with an animal
you gotta treat him like it I you know
you gotta hose him down
I don't know what you'd do
just break one of his glasses in front
of him
just say let's just start throwing out
his dishes go look I'm not going to wash
them so I'm just going to put your
dishes in the trash
okay which is ridiculous and it'll be
like why go back because I'm not your
[__] [__]
do your dishes you [__] animal I
would literally take it I mean I don't
know I don't know if you can take this
guy but like I don't know let's make
it's making me go back to an angry place
in my life so I'm not gonna give you any
more advice don't do that don't bring it
to violence don't stick as pillow in the
toilet don't do that
it's a short time in your [__] life
you'll get a better roommate but uh just
you learn a lot of lessons with this
[__] and uh when you go to meet a woman
uh you know check out her [__]
apartment see how she lives
all right and don't do a one and done
either see how she is over time she's a
[__] there's nothing worse than a
messy woman they have way more [__] than
any guy could ever have just imagine all
your [__] male roommate [__] just
multiply the amount of sneakers he has
times 20 [__] pairs of shoes all that
makeup and crap
[__] animals I used to clean
bathrooms and um
when I worked in this restaurant
and you'd think the guy's bathroom would
have been dirtier the [__] woman's
bathroom I swear to God
it looked like there was a ticker tape
parade and then somebody [__] all over
it
it's a [__] water all over the
it was like what the [__] are they doing
in here
and because they have to sit down to pee
they were just building nests I don't
know what it was it was just an ungodly
amount of toilet paper all over the
[__] place and
it'll get dolled up in there and that
was just oh God it was [__] horror
show
um all right stamps.com everybody
you know that feeling you can get when
you can get things done with just a
click of the mouse you know that great
goddamn feeling it can't get more
convenient than that and now you can
even get your mailing and shipping done
without leaving your desk thanks to
stamps.com
turn your PC or Mac into your own
personal post office that never closes
talk about convenient buy-in print
official U.S postage with any letter or
package
um using your computer and printer then
just hand your mail to the mailman drop
it off at the mailbox and you never have
to go to the post office again I use
stamps.com to send out all my posters
that I sell at the end of my shows I'm a
[__] if I can figure it out so can you
right now use my last name Burr for this
special offer no risk trial plus 110
bonus offer includes a digital scale
calculates exact postage for letters and
packages and up to fifty five dollars
free postage don't wait go to stamps.com
before you do anything else click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in Burr Burr that stamps.com